بين فينه واخرى منذ بدايه العمليه
العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا يلتقي
بالعسكريين الروس وسكان تلك المناطق
واحيانا كثيره يغني لهم عن الوطن
والبطولات عن الشجاعه والتضحيات
[موسيقى]
ري احد الفنانين والمثقفين الروس الذين
يدعمون قرارات القياده الروسيه في
اوكرانيا ويعبرون عن ولائهم لها
كل من يدرك في اي دوله نعيش وضد من موجهه
لعمليه العسكريه يفعل ما في وسعه ليعبر عن
دعمه لذلك منا من ينشط في الجبهات ومن
يقدم المساعدات لسكان تلك المناطق واخرون
ينظمون الحفلات لقواتنا ويعبرون عن
تاييدهم للعمليه العسكريه في وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي والاعلام
لكن هناك من ينتقد ويرفض هذه العمليه
العسكريه جمله وتفصيله تتجلى هذه المعارضه
اكثر في صفوف من فر من روسيا ولجا الى دول
اخرى رمان احدهم هؤلاء الشباب حاول
التعبير في اغانيه عن تجربه الانفصال عن
الوطن باطلاق مشروع غنائي يستند الى قصائد
شعراء موجه الهجره الاولى التي شهدتها
البلاد في عشرينيات القرن الماضي
ومقارنه تجربتهم القصريه باحداث اليوم
مقدار هذا الجيل تتقاطع بشكل ماساوي مع
مقدار جيل المهاجرين الروس في القرن
الماضي ولذلك كان من الطبيعي بذل نوع من
التفاني ومد الجسور بين معاناه ذلك الجيل
وهذا عبر الاغنيه ولذلك اطلقنا هذا
المشروع الذي يعد الاكبر لدى الموجه
الجديده للهجره الروسيه
تشابكت الامور اكثر بعد فرض الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه عقوبات شملت عشرات الفنانين
والصحفيين الروس المؤيدين للحرب وما قبله
من رد فعل روسي بحق من يعارضها من تضييق
وتعليق للعروض وصولا الى مقترحات تدعو الى
سلب ممتلكاتهم بالقانون
كلها يراد لها ان تكون قريبه من الانسان
اكثر لكن اليوم في القرن الحادي والعشرين
بات ذلك جزءا لا يتجزا من المواجهه
السياسيه التي تمارسها الدول وهو ما تجلى
واضحا في احداث اوكرانيا والتصعيد الروسي
الغربي
الجزيره موسكو